[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحدة أكد أكثر من 16000 شخص
احتمال إصابتهم بجدري القردة
جميعهم تقريبًا في البالغين
ولكن انتقال هذا الفيروس
يحدث عادةً عن طريق ملامسة الجلد للجلد وإذا
كنت تعلم أن الأطفال على اتصال
بشخص مصاب
ستصاب بالعدوى بينما
يظل خطر كرات القردة للأطفال في سن المدرسة
منخفضًا ، تم الإبلاغ عن 17 حالة مؤكدة أو محتملة بين
الأطفال الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 15 عامًا
إلى مركز السيطرة على الأمراض هذا الأسبوع في مقاطعة نيوتن في
جورجيا ، وهي حالة مؤكدة في
طالب في مدرسة ابتدائية طالب آخر
في
يتم أيضًا اختبار مدرسة مختلفة في المنطقة التعليمية على
مسؤولي النظام المدرسي قائلين إن الموظفين سيقومون
بتنظيف وتطهير
الفصول الدراسية تمامًا في مناطق أخرى في كلتا
المدرستين ، وأعتقد أننا لسنا بحاجة إلى الذعر
بشأن هذا ، وأعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى البقاء على
اطلاع ولكن الحالات في الأطفال مثل
قلت بالفعل إن أقل من واحد في
المائة من إجمالي الحالات التي نراها
لتوفير حماية إضافية لخبراء الصحة يقولون إن
الآباء يمكنهم التعرف على نفسك
مع الأعراض ، احتفظ بالأطفال في المنزل إذا كانوا
يعانون من الحمى والطفح الجلدي ، تحدث إلى
طبيب الأطفال الخاص بك لأن العديد من الأمراض
تسبب الحمى والطفح الجلدي ، اغسل اليدين
وتنظيف وتطهير الأسطح عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالكليات والجامعات
، أطلق مركز السيطرة على الأمراض صفحة هبوط جديدة تحتوي على
موارد جدري القردة  لدينا بروتوكول كامل
معمول به لمساعدة الأشخاص على تقييم
اللحظة الصحية أنا ماندي جيثر